investors this morning hope for a
rebound in US stocks after another day
of big losses all three major indexes
were hit hard the Dow Jones Industrials
fell 459 points yesterday that's almost
2% that followed new Chinese tariffs on
more than 100 US products and president
Trump's criticism of tech giant Amazon
William Cohen is a Vanity Fair special
correspondent and author of why Wall
Street matters and he is joining us now
to go through all of this great to have
you on set so here this is the worst
start to the second quarter since the
Great Depression how much of this is
driven by the president's comments or
actions be that on trade tariffs with
China or going after Amazon directly
look there's a confluence of events of
which the president's commentary and
tweets and policies whether it's related
to self-inflicted wounds related to
steel tariffs and aluminum tariffs that
come together I mean there's fed
deciding it's going to increase interest
rates after close to 10 years of a zero
interest rate policy investors don't
like that as much as they can anticipate
that they don't like that last year the
market went up you know 35 40 percent in
anticipation of a big tax changes to the
tax bill and a tax law that has now
happened and people are trying to digest
it and figure it out then there are the
self-inflicted wounds whether it's the
tweeting about Amazon or or trying to
break up various media mergers that
don't have in particular logic why go
after the AT&T Time Warner deal because
you don't like CNN why not go after the
Disney Fox deal but you don't do that
because you like Rupert Murdoch why
attack Amazon on on Twitter because you
don't like the Washington Post that Jeff
Bezos happens to already own as well so
there's a confluence of events nobody
rings a bell at the top of the market
and says you know we're at the top it's
gonna be down from here but in my view
sort of like Warren Buffett this is a
healthy market correction if your long
term bullish on America and America and
Industry is as you should be because
that's proven to be the case over
generations then then you should as the
SVN intro said everybody should just
calm down and that you view this as a
buying opportunity so these these fit
relations and
market you say it's a healthy that would
suggest that it's based on the actual
progress of the economy real things are
posted tweets which are we're all
learning whether to take those seriously
or not as they affect actual policy so
so how do you pull those two apart
what's regular well unfortunately
there's a confluence right some of it it
relates to the real economy like if you
raise interest rates which is the feds
duty to sort of take the punchbowl away
just as the party is getting started
which they're now committed to doing
then that means that the money is gonna
cost more it's not gonna be quite as
available and but it's not we're not
talking about big moves we're talking
about after zero interest rate policy
for ten years we're talking about you
know 75 basis points it's not that's not
a lot but we have a high beta president
who cannot be predicted high beta if
LeMat o'clock and you can't predict what
he's gonna do a self-inflicted wounds on
tariffs which causes China to put
tariffs on our goods
you know investors don't like that CEOs
don't like that
what's he doing with antitrust policy
CEOs don't like that they can't figure
out the rhyme or reason so people get
nervous and by the way it's kind of
healthy to have this correction stocks
got really crazy last year what happen
if Jeff Bezos buys Twitter mm-hmm I
think a great idea and shut it down
either the whole company or some certain
accounts I saw that online too but way
not if all this is healthy well that'd
be healthy too that would be fun a nice
counterterrorism they're always good to
have you at the table I feel